the screen to protect his privacy was
the giveaway
a month after being admitted the duke of
edinburgh was leaving the king edward
vii
hospital photographers able to get
pictures that prince philip would
probably rather we didn't see
as he was taken back to windsor to be
reunited with the queen
despite some of those photographs i
understand the duke is
in good spirits and in their statement
the palace more than anything want to
stress
how much he wants to thank those who've
treated him
and all those who sent their good wishes
while he's been in hospital
the prince of wales out in london
promoting the vaccination program
seemed delighted his father had gone
home
prince philip went in four weeks ago to
be treated for an infection
but two weeks in a pre-existing heart
condition meant he had some form of
surgery
cardiologist dr igval malik says rest
and physiotherapy
is what he now needs to rebuild his
strength whatever procedure he had
it can take you know weeks to months to
get back to the level of activity he was
in
even six weeks ago because those muscles
need to be built up again
and if you're a young person and you
break your leg the muscles recover
pretty quickly
if you're old and you break your leg it
takes a lot longer
the physiotherapy the rehabilitation is
really important
last summer the prince looked in great
spirits which is why his hospital stay
came as a surprise a worrying time for
the queen
left to deal with the fallout from the
sussex's interview with oprah
without her husband by her side the
queen will be delighted to have prince
philip home it's been a tough few weeks
for her
obviously concerned about his health and
there have been issues in the public
sphere
and she always uses prince philip's wise
guidance to counsel her
the prince and the palace won't have
like the international speculation about
his health
he can now recuperate in his own time
away from the public eye
riannon mills sky news at windsor castle